I
[Music]
The Bachelor that shows also returning
tonight so grab a glass of wine and get
ready to judge ladies cuz we've got a
sneak peek as Nick Viall begins his
fourth attempt at finding mrs. right I'm
super indeed fourth time's the charm ?
well there's tears a make out on a yacht
a suit for dramatic slap and a surprise
contestant who is someone from Nick's
past it doesn't know who I just seems a
little bit weird that she's here all
weekend reveal is that Liz a 29 year old
baby doula met Nick before there was
alcohol involved and missed
opportunities of course we also get to
see 30 creative and crazy entrances of
Nick's wannabe loves one comes riding in
on a camel there's a shark costume a
food truck and a cheerleading lesson and
a contested freak out what it's like get
to know somebody in like it's hard but
for some real dish on episode one we
sent ET on lines lauren zima to go
one-on-one with a 36 year old software
salesman they played a game called the
vaio files we go into Nick's past and we
learn all about and things they might
not have known what are your turn ons I
think it's really sexy when a girl can
dress down and still look really good I
thought I like it like jeans and
converse what is the biggest challenge
about dating you I think I'm not to keep
up with you know I mean I like a good
fight what physical feature are you
least confident about my shoulders a
little narrow do you think I don't know
my nose might be a little crooked
[Music]